[Music]
Mikey scared of everything finds a book
the book that he finds it's called the
dragon Prince and he's scared to read it
because his pictures of scary dragons in
it but then he gets the courage to read
it cuz he sees a little boy in there too
that kind of looks like he knows what's
going on so he sees that little boy
doesn't want to read it and in the book
the king is dead and the boy is now the
only one that will defend the kingdom
from the Dragons that are over the hill
in the dragon cave and the boy is scared
cuz he only seven years old
it isn't always gonna do does it finds
his father's war chest pulls out the
shield pulls out the sword they're too
big for him and now he's even more
scared of that he sees a note in the
bottom of the war chest and he picks up
the note and here's what it says to my
son
[Music]
our kingdom is now what you must save
and to do that you have to be brave the
dragons they aren't really that big at
all it is only in our minds that we make
them so tall inside our brains things
always get overblown especially things
that are completely unknown stand up
straight and hold your head high and
look your fears right in the eye don't
look away but don't try to hide know
that you have great strength
deep inside fear is normal for every
person on earth but this is where a hero
pours his worth
[Music]